-Thank you for coming back
to the show.
-Thank you for having me back.
-What are you talking about?
Since we've last talked on the
show, you've had a crazy ride.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Congratulations.
You won an Oscar.
-Thank you.
I did. I did. I did. I did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah!
-Look at this.
-I know. Crazy.
So did that guy over there.
He won an Oscar, too.
-Questlove got one, too.
-No, no, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on! That's amazing!
-That was a great night.
-Yeah.
-You made history as being
the first Afro-Latina
and first
openly queer woman of color
to win an Oscar for acting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
I know it's a mouthful,
but thank you.
I appreciate it.
-No, you know, but I wanted to
tell you out here
that your speech was so moving
and so perfectly said
and well-put.
Everyone was crying happy tears
and just so psyched and proud.
I mean, what did that feel
and how did you feel
when you got off the stage?
You're like -- Did you know
that you nailed it?
Because you nailed it.
-You know,
it was really surreal.
-Yeah, it was.
-God, I don't even
really know how to describe it.
-Do you remember them
saying your name
and you getting up and --
-I did.
I really just wanted to cry.
But that's not
the moment you cry.
You get up.
You've got to walk
and you've got to say something.
And I remember thinking,
"Oh, this is the time
to say what you want to say."
And that's what I wanted to say,
that there was a place for us.
And it's such a,
like, point of joy for me,
especially right now,
because we've got to
hold on to our joy, people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, we do.
You got to hold on to your joy.
-Oh, yeah.
-So, I was just so grateful.
And, I mean,
I never expected to be
standing in the same spot
Julia Roberts stood.
You know what I mean?
Like, Denzel Washington
stood there.
Like, it was just --
I don't know.
It was really cool.
-But, also, I loved the detail
of your speech.
It was like, "To the little girl
in the back of a --"
Was it a Ford --
-A Ford Focus,
a white Ford Focus.
-A white Ford Focus.
That immediately set
the stage for me.
And I go, "Oh, I love you."
I love that you said that,
'cause that is exactly real.
That's descriptive, and it was
like, it really happened to you.
-Well, it's good to remind
people, like,
who you are, you know?
It's like, yes, I get dressed
and I look like this every day,
but, like, that's a real person.
That's a real little girl.
That little girl
still exists, you know?
Like, and there's a little girl
out there in
a white Ford Focus right now,
and she needs to know that
her dreams are possible.
-That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-That's what I felt.
That's what came across.
I loved it.
So, now you have the Oscar.
Where do you keep the Oscar?
Is this one of those things
where, like,
it's a doorstop or you --
-Oh, no.
-Toilet paper on it.
-I am so not there yet.
Like, I know that works for
Dame Emma Thompson,
who I happen to love.
Like, work Queen.
But, for me, I'm like,
"Nah, this is too important."
So, I actually have
a fully functioning fireplace,
believe it or not,
that's either
really dangerous or awesome.
-In New York City?
-In New York City.
-Good for you.
-Thank you so much. I love it.
-Wow.
-But I have it on my mantel,
in addition to the other,
like, blessings, the accolades
that I received this season.
And on my way to my coffeemaker
in the morning, I just pass by
and I'm like,
"Yeah, good things can happen."
Like, you work hard,
don't be a dick, be kind,
you know, like, good things
can happen for people.
Put in the effort.
-Yeah, be kind,
be a good person.
-Yeah, just don't suck,
man, please.
I am so tired of people sucking.
-Yes.
-Like, be nice.
-Just be nice.
-Kindness is free, people.
It don't cost you nothing
to be kind.
-That's exactly right.
-I can't do it. So...
-So, not only that, then
I saw you -- We were at a thing,
and I saw you and I go,
"Are you nervous for the Tonys?"
And you're like, "Yeah, I am.
I'm a little nervous."
And I go,
"That's my favorite award show.
It's live and it's --"
-It's great.
-Oh, I love it.
I love the energy.
I love the whole -- I mean,
what talent in that room.
And to just, like, show off
in front of so many talented
people watching you,
and just like --
-Oh, I was just nervous.
I wanted to throw up.
-You nailed it, buddy.
-Thank you.
-You nailed it,
and I go, "Ooh, yes!"
And then you stuck the landing.
I go, "Oh, my gosh!"
It was so good.
-Oh, I love that.
For you,
it felt like a football game.
-Yes.
-Like, "Touchdown!"
-Yeah, no, I was screaming.
I was like, "Ooh, yes!
Oh, nailed it.
Oh, that's funny.
Oh, that's good.
Oh, you look good."
-Well, that means a lot to me,
because I'm not a comedian.
Like, I don't do what
you do every day.
I'm not Whoopi Goldberg or
Billy Crystal for that matter.
So when they asked me to do it,
I was like,
"Oh, this is something
I didn't know I wanted to do."
-Yeah.
-But I like hosting.
And I like doing it my way,
'cause, not for nothing,
I like people.
So, I just was like,
"Okay, let me do what I do."
And I know Broadway.
Like, I spent
10 years on Broadway.
And I wanted to
create an evening
that was just celebratory
and brought some joy.
I know it's annoying,
but, like, joy.
-Yeah, it was
the first show back.
-Back at Radio City.
And I wanted it to be grand
and sexy and fun
and new and a little different.
And, not for nothing,
those folks working on Broadway
eight times a week --
they deserved a good night.
-Exactly right.
They put the work in.
-Yes.
So, I'm so glad you liked it.
-I loved it.
You know,
there was a great quote I read
maybe from NPR or
something I heard from NPR,
and they said, "Ariana DeBose
should host everything."
I was like, "That's fantastic."
-That's nervous.
That makes me nervous.
-But that's a good review
right there, yeah.
-I'll take it, but yikes!
-Yeah.
-Ew!
-It is --
Today is the last official day
of Pride Month,
and I know that you are
a big supporter and advocate.
What comes to your mind
as we're getting to
the end of Pride Month?
-You know, I'm thinking about
a lot at the end of Pride Month.
And I think -- I just want to
remind, you know,
all my LGBTQAI+
brothers and sisters, like,
don't stop being you.
You know, fight for your dreams,
fight for your joy,
and remember, like,
you are -- you're valid.
I say it a lot,
but it's important.
And it's also important to
remember that we're in a fight.
You know, we can talk a lot
about how the Supreme Court
has just waged war on
women's reproductive rights,
but the reality is,
Clarence Thomas was
very clear on what his plan is.
He's not just coming for women.
They already came for
voting rights.
They're going to continue.
But they're coming for
marriage equality.
And, quite frankly,
they'll probably come for
adoption rights
by same-sex couples.
So this is
the time to get in the fight,
and it starts on a local level.
So find ways to get involved.
I personally,
because I -- Come on.
I'm black. I'm Afro-Latina.
I'm a woman, and I'm queer.
My country is at war with me,
and that's hard.
Oh, my God, that's hard.
But the only thing I can do is
hold on to my joy
and make a difference
at a local level.
So I'm trying to find
the abortion funds
in my community
that I can support
so I can help anyone
with a uterus,
whether that means getting them
to a safe-haven state
or, in the states that don't
want to support them,
how can we support them?
So, I want to encourage folks to
research, get involved,
but do your part, because this
is not about one set of rights.
It's about human rights.
-Yeah.
-And I will -- I'm sorry to be
on a soapbox,
but I'm not sorry.
I'm fired up and I want
everybody else to be, too.
-Be fired up. Be fired up!
-I'm so fired up!
-Yeah, be fired up!
-But you know what?
This is a terrible analogy,
but I like it.
This is a time of
planting seeds, right?
Because seeds beget roots
and hopefully
really healthy trees.
We've got a rotten-ass tree
called the Supreme Court
and we've got to root it out.
-Yeah.
-So do your part, people.
-Yeah. That's right.
Thank you. Thank you, though.
Thank you.
Thank you. I appreciate this.
I do also want to --
I want to talk about
"Westworld," by the way.
-Yeah.
-You know we had
Evan Rachel Wood on the show.
-I know, and she did this crazy
Janis Joplin impression.
-Was that amazing?
-Like, come on.
She is incredible.
-Yeah, she was amazing.
But she was like,
"Yeah, we have a great season."
And I did not know that you were
joining the "Westworld" gang.
-Yeah, it was, like,
a surprise to me, too.
No, for real.
We shot this
during the pandemic.
And I was really waiting for
"West Side Story"
to be released to the world,
because nobody really knew
what I did in the film.
So, I got this
e-mail about making
a tape for an untitled project.
And so I made
a one-minute video.
And they -- It turned out
to be for "Westworld."
-Yeah.
-And they were like, "Cool.
So, we want you
to come be on the show
for a character we
can't really tell you about."
And I was like, "Okay."
-"Yes, I'm going to do this,"
but you really have to
trust them.
-Yeah. So, I chatted with
the showrunners
and I watched
the first season of the show.
And I'm not going to lie.
I got busy with a little show
called "Hamilton," so I --
-Yeah.
So, I didn't get to see
the subsequent seasons.
But I liked what I saw and
I thought it was really special.
-It's all so beautiful.
They're almost like
they make movies, almost.
They look like movies.
-It is.
It's cinematic art,
in my opinion.
And also what I learned
is that they shoot on film,
and there aren't
many television shows
who do shoot on film these days.
-Yeah. "The Tonight Show" does.
Yeah, our show and "Westworld."
We do all of our shows on film.
Yeah. They want to really make
sure -- Yeah, we do film.
But that's tricky.
-Yeah. It's tricky.
And that just means you have to
show up and be present.
We shot "West Side Story"
on film, so every take counts.
And I was like, "Okay,
I'm going to say yes to this."
And I went on the ride.
And I'm still on the ride
because I have no idea
how the show turned out.
So I'm very invested
in the season.
-Yeah. I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Ariana DeBose
and Evan Rachel Wood
in this Sunday's episode
of "Westworld."
Take a look.
-Couldn't sleep.
I just kept
thinking about that guy.
They told me I ruined his life.
-Christina, if he confused
a game with his life,
it's because his life
was already ruined.
I mean, come on.
Died suddenly, ex-wife.
Hope Center for Mental Health
is his charity of choice.
-How do you know that?
-It's right here.
In his obituary.
-His story --
I think I might have
written something like this.
-Doesn't change the fact
that he was certifiable.
And you want to know how I know?
He jumped off a roof.
-Ooh!
Ariana DeBose, everybody.
You can see "Westworld"
Sundays at 9:00 p.m. on HBO.